PROFESSOR: Now you may remember
a discussion of the birthday
paradox, which says
that if you have
a group of 27 random people.
The probability is almost
2/3 that two of them
are going to have a matching
birthday, even though there
are 365 birthdays in the year.
You might sloppily think
that with 27 people
there'd only be a 27 out of
365, or some chance like that.
It's actually 2/3.
And by the time you
get to a class of 110--
which is what we have
data for and we're
going to be looking
at-- it turns out
that the odds are almost
3/4 of a million to one
that you'll have a couple of
people with matching birthdays.
So let's look at the matching
birthday problem a little bit
more today.
And the reason
we're looking at it
is because it's a lovely
example where there really
is pairwise independence,
and not mutual independence.
So it's reinforcing the key
idea behind the additivity
of variance, and the pairwise
independent sampling theorem.
We're not going to use the
sampling theorem here, but just
pairwise independence,
but it's worth looking at.
Now before I go
further let me mention
that the birthday problem is
just what we're doing for fun.
But in fact, it has
some real applications
in more than one area,
but the most famous one
is the so-called birthday
attack on a cryptosystem, which
involves being able to search
for matching pairs of keys
with a relatively small sample.
And you're very likely to
find at least two that match.
So with that motivation
claimed, but not examined,
let's just go back to
thinking about birthdays.
OK so let's suppose that I
have some group of n people,
and there are
d-days in the year,
just to keep the
parameters abstract
and not get too
stuck on the numbers.
Keeping the parameters
makes it actually
clearer to reason about.
So we're implicitly
assuming here
that each person is kind
of a random variable,
or a random choice
of a birthday.
So each of these
people are really
random variables that return
the value of a birthday.
And it is a matter
of fact, we're
going assume that all the
birthdays are equally likely.
Real birthdays aren't.
They tend to be of January
tends to be a popular month,
November tends to be a more
popular month than other times.
But let's ignore that because
if the applications in crypto
things really are uniform.
And it makes our analysis
plausible, still plausible
but easy if we
assume that birthdays
are equally likely, OK.
P is the number of pairs
of birthdays that match
in this population of n people.
OK, let's get a grip
on p by thinking
of it as a sum of
indicator variables.
So let's let M sub ij be
the indicator variable
that ith and jith people among
the n have a matching birthday.
Well the number of
matching birthdays
is then simply the sum over all
the possible pairs of people of
whether or not they have
a matching birthday.
It's the sum of these
indicator variables M sub ij.
And the number of these
indicator variables
is of course all the ways of
choosing two out of n people.
So in short, if I look at
the expectation M sub ij,
let's think about
that for a minute.
We're assuming that all the
birthdays are equally likely.
And so I'm asking whether
the ith and the jith people
have the same birthday.
Well whatever the ith's
person birthday turns out
to be, let's say
it's November 5,
the jth person, who has
a uniform probability
of equalling any birthday, still
has a uniform probability 1
chance in d of equalling
November 5, which
happens to be my birthday.
OK so in short the probability
that any two people
have a matching birthday
is one chance in d.
And that means that
the expectation
of the indicator variable
for that event, M sub ij,
is 1 over d.
And that tells us, by
linearity of expectation,
that the expected
number of pairs
is simply the number
of those pairs
times the expected
number per pair,
and choose 2 times 1 over d.
Well as I said we have
data for 110 students.
So the expected number of pairs
in a collection in a student
body of 110 is 110 choose,
2 times 1 over 365,
or about 16.4 pairs is the
expected number of pairs
of matching birthdays.
OK, now that's an
expected value.
How likely is it to be if I take
a selection of 110 students,
and I count how many
pairs of birthdays
are there, do I really expect
to get close to 16.4 or not?
Well what we're asking for
is the probability that p
is near its mean, that the
distance between P and 16.4
is greater than k.
I hope that as k gets bigger
this probability is small.
And so I'm really quite likely
to have close to 16.4 birthdays
in my sample of 110.
But this probability is one
that's a mess to calculate.
But we can get a grip on it
because the variance of P
is easy to calculate.
And that will allow us to
apply the Chebyshev bound,
and get some kind of an
estimate on the likelihood
that P is near its expectation.
So the key observation
that we need
is that the indicator variables
are pairwise independent.
So let's think
about the indicator
variable for the event that
the ith and the jth people
have the same birthday, let's
call them Albert and Drew.
So Albert's the ith person,
Drew is the jth person.
And I'm interested in the
event that Albert and Drew
have the same birthday.
And let's compare that to
another pair of people,
and whether or not they
have the same birthday.
So let's first of all
think about Dave and Mike,
whether Dave and Mike
have the same birthday.
And I want to know if these
two events are independent.
Well remember we are assuming
that Albert's birthday is
independent of Drew's birthday
is independent of David's, is
independent of Mike.
Each of the people is
supposedly chosen independently,
and their birthdays
are independent.
So it's obvious that these
two pairs that don't overlap
have nothing to do
with each other,
and we don't have
to worry about that.
You could prove that
formally, but it is obvious
because each of the individual
birthdays are independent.
Now what's more
interesting is the case
when I asked whether or
not Albert and Drew having
the same birthday is
independent of Albert and Mike
having the same birthday.
And that one is not so obvious.
Here's a way to think
about what could go wrong.
Suppose that in fact the
birthdays weren't uniform,
suppose that some birthdays
were more common than others.
OK that makes it more likely
that if Albert and Drew have
the same birthday
it slants things,
so that they're more likely to
have this very common birthday
than they would
have been otherwise.
And now once I know that
they match, and therefore are
more likely to have the common
birthday than they would have
without any information,
I know that Albert
is more likely to have this
common birthday than otherwise.
And that means that Mike is even
more likely to match Albert,
because Albert's got the
common birthday than Mike
was to match Albert without any
further information about what
Albert's likely birthday was.
You can think about that, and it
can be worked out numerically,
easily enough.
So uniform is going to be a
crucial factor here in order
to conclude that
Albert and Drew,
and Albert and Mike are
mutually independent events.
But let's go back
and think about it.
All we really need is
that Mike is uniform
in order to conclude that these
two events are independent.
Because we know that Mike
and Andrew and Albert
separately are
independent of each other.
Their birthdays are
chosen independently.
So that intuitively means
that the probability that Mike
has any given birthday
doesn't really
matter what's going on
with Albert and Drew,
because Mike is independent
of Albert and Drew.
And if we know that Mike's
probability of having
a birthday is uniform,
then whatever the birthday
that Albert has, whether
he matches Drew or not,
Mike has a 1 chance
in d of hitting
the same birthday of whatever
Albert wound up having.
And that means that the
probability that Mike matches
Albert is the same one over d
than it would have been if we
had no further information.
This is an argument that,
in fact, is made rigorous
in some class problems
and a problem set,
but let's just take
it as plausible enough
based on this hand-waving
argument that I articulated,
that these two events are
independent pairwise and so
the corresponding indicator
variables and M Albert Drew,
and M Albert Mike are
independent of each other.
So that's what we've argued.
But notice that these
events of pairwise matching
are certainly not
three-way independent,
because after all if I know
that Albert and Drew have
the same birthday, and
that Albert and Mike have
the same birthday,
I absolutely know
with certainty that Drew and
Mike have the same birthday.
So this is a very
nice, basic example
where you have pairwise
independence, but not
three-way independence,
assuming that
all of these random variables
Albert, Drew, and Mike are
uniform in what
birthday they have.
OK so let's go back
to counting birthdays.
The variance of an
indicator is pq.
So in this case p is 1 over 365,
and q is 1 minus 1 over 365.
And because of
pairwise independence,
the variance of p, which
is the sum of the M sub
ijs, the variance of the
number of birthday pairs,
is the sum of those variances.
It's 110 choose to times
the variance of the M sub ij
turns out to be
about 16.37, which
means that the standard
deviation sigma is less than 4.
Now I can apply Chebyshev,
because by the Chebyshev band
the probability that
16.4 is within a 2
sigma, is further
away than 2 sigma,
is only one chance in four.
Which means the probability
that it's within 2 sigma,
that the actual number
of measured pairs
is within 2 sigma of
the expected number 16.4
is greater than 1
minus 1/4, or 3/4.
There's a 3/4 chance that the
number of pairs that we find
is within 2 sigma of the
expected number 16.4.
Sigma was about 4,
so this is 8, which
means that we're expecting,
with 3/4 probability,
somewhere between 8.4, meaning
9, and 24.4, meaning 25 pairs.
So 75% of the time,
in a class of 110,
we're going to find between
9 and 25 pairs of birthdays.
Did that actually happen?
Well it did.
In our class of 110
for whom we had data,
we actually found 21 pairs
of matching birthdays.
Literally we found 12
pairs and three triples,
but each triple counts
as three matching pairs.
And there they are,
the blues are triples.
And you can see
whether your birthday
is among those, and
knowing that you
have a classmate or two
that have the same birthday
that you do.
So there are 15
different birthdays,
but they count as 21
pairs because it's
12 single pairs, and three
triplets, each of which
counts for three pairs.